SPEAKER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
OK, any burning
issues from last time or
earlier, before I begin?
OK, we're going to do a little
primer on climate science
and a very little primer
on the science and a primer
on the policy.
This could easily take
more than a semester.
But we'll do it in
an hour and a half.
So what I'm going to mostly do
is do what economists often do,
which is to say, well, let's
suppose we have a tsar.
Let's suppose we have a
tsar, who can set policy.
What would the tsar
do about climate?
Let's assume it's a modern
tsar, not a denyist tsar.
I'm going to argue
and try to indicate
to you why, even for a tsar,
this would be a hard problem.
This is the hardest
public policy
problem I've ever come near.
So today, we have a tsar.
Wednesday and Friday, we don't.
It's like the real world.
And we will go through a
negotiation in which you
will be, as you know, on teams.
We'll talk a little bit
about that at the end
because we're going to have
to do some adjustments.
You all want to
be rich countries.
You can't all be rich countries.
Some of you have to be poor.
It's like life.
All right, so let me do a
very little bit of background
on the science and then talk
about why it's a hard policy
problem.
You've probably seen this graph.
This is from NASA.
Global temperatures are rising.
If you look at the
last few years,
it looks like a slowdown.
This has been much debated.
The latest evidence
suggests this
is because of La Nina
conditions in the Pacific,
which tend to lower
the temperature.
And solar radiation is at
a minimum in its cycle.
Those who follow
these things closely
expect, when we go to El Nino
conditions in the Pacific,
that we will break
previous records.
Nine of the 10 warmest
years on record
have been in this century.
So if you smooth,
and you see there's
a lot of variability year
to year, if you smooth,
the trend is reasonably clear.
That's data.
This is inference.
There's strong evidence,
backed by theory,
that human activity has
a lot to do with this.
This is a global greenhouse
emissions by gas in 2004.
You'll see, on the right,
CO2 from fossil fuel use
is a big contributor,
not the only contributor.
I think CO2 other is
probably cement manufacture.
This is land use, deforestation,
biomass, agriculture,
and so forth.
Methane, nitrous oxide, which
is a nasty, long-lived gas,
largely comes from agriculture.
Methane comes, of course,
from a variety of sources.
And then there are a
bunch of long-lived,
very potent, but very small,
very low-concentration gases.
This is by sector.
And again, you can see
an awful lot of this
is human activity obviously,
but generating electricity,
manufacturing, transportation.
And again, you get
land use and forestry.
So it's a range.
This is later data, but
it doesn't show it by gas.
There are a wide variety
of activities involved
that emit heat-trapping gases.
And again, there's
evidence, there's
theory that suggests that
this is really a driver.
The changes in solar
radiation, the El Nino, La Nina
is not big enough.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] put the
carbon content [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Largely.
You also lose soil carbon.
If you cultivate and till
the soil, you'll lose.
You'll have an effect.
You'll reduce what's
stored in the soil.
So it's mostly deforestation.
But it can also be just
agricultural practices.
OK.
But deforestation is crucial.
We're going to talk mostly
about CO2 from fossil fuels
because that's where
the policy action is
and also deforestation.
Mostly because you can
measure fossil fuel use
relatively easily.
Figuring out how agriculture
generates nitrous oxide
is harder, much
harder to measure.
But fuel use is relatively easy.
Deforestation is
relatively easy to measure.
So you can actually
imagine agreements
that might be enforceable.
So that's where the
policy action is.
We also know-- whoops.
Back.
We also know that there
have been some clear impacts
of climate change.
This is everybody's seen this.
This is the change in sea
ice since September of '79
to September of 2007.
And obviously, that continues.
This is a projection.
And it can only be a
projection, for reasons
I want to talk about, of
days over 100 degrees.
And you see, gee, there,
it gets hot in the desert.
But the problem with this
is mainly human health.
People who are fragile
in a variety of ways
or who aren't air
conditioned don't deal well
with large numbers of
days over 100 degrees.
It happened in Europe
a couple of years ago.
There were a number of--
more than a number, a
fair number of deaths.
So these are obvious impacts.
If it gets warmer, you
have more hot days.
If it gets warmer,
the sea ice melts.
But that's a small part
of the story is warming.
So why is this hard?
Why is this a hard
policy problem?
Step reason one is
the time scales.
And the time scales, CO2 doesn't
come out of the atmosphere
by simple exponential decay.
The process is complicated.
But if you think
about a half life,
you want to think about
around a century, if you can
think of it in half life terms.
Not only does the stuff
stay up there a long time,
but it takes a long
time for its effects.
For the Earth to be in
equilibrium, depending
on how much heat is coming
in and being trapped,
you got to warm the deep ocean.
The deep ocean is deep.
Heat diffuses slowly.
So it takes a while to warm.
So we're not in equilibrium now.
And the question of how far
out of equilibrium we are
is kind of a serious one.
So even if you cut
emissions sharply now,
warming would
continue for decades.
Given that we're not going
to cut emissions sharply,
we're dealing with centuries.
And in this literature,
people run out
to 2100 and typically out
beyond 2100 in thinking
about a variety of things.
Most human problems don't
have time scales like that.
It means that
actions taken today
will affect your grandchildren.
That's not true in
most areas of policy.
You can do tax policy
lots between now
and the time your
grandchildren vote.
But CO2, it's still
going to be there.
The CO2 emitted today will
still be there in large quantity
when your grandchildren
are walking
around blaming you for it.
So if we have a
climate tsar, he has
to think about how to
treat people not yet born
because actions today will
affect people not yet born.
I mean this is a
typical example.
This is somebody's
story of what gets
flooded in Florida if you get
about a meter sea level rise.
A meter sea level rise is
sort of order of magnitude
what might happen in a century.
What's it worth today
to prevent that in 2112?
For reference, my mother
lives there, more or less.
So she's OK.
On the other hand,
she's 90 years old.
This doesn't apply to her.
But it will apply, potentially,
to great-great-grandchildren.
So timescales of
a century or more
are hard because you
know you want a discount.
But how do you do that?
This is a live controversy.
I'm not going to
give you an answer.
Economists have nasty
arguments about this.
There are three ways you
might want to think about it.
The obvious way to
think about, what
am I going to do about
a century from now,
is to just think about
the private sector.
Well, I could put it in a
bank, or I could invest it
in a business, or
I could invest it
in dealing with climate change.
I make that choice.
So I ought to be using the
same kind of discounting
in both decisions, right?
Because I don't want
to have an imbalance.
You missed the science.
You could have fixed it.
This is Professor Solomon
who has forgotten more
about climate science than I
could ever aspire to learn.
At any rate, we're
talking about policy.
And we're talking
about discounting
and why this is hard.
So one school of
thought says, you've
got to use a private
sector discount rate.
And one reason this
school of thought
achieved prominence was the
Army Corps of Engineers, when
deciding whether or
not to build dams,
always used a very
low discount rate.
Dams last a long time.
So if you use a very
low discount rate,
dams look pretty
promising economically.
And it was a huge slog
in the '50s and '60s
to get the Corps of Engineers
to use a private sector
rate, to say, you can
build this kind of plant,
or you can build a dam.
You ought to use the same
discount rate in both cases.
You ought to use the private
sector rate to think about
whether or not you build dams.
There's a second school
of thought that says,
wait a minute.
This isn't really a
private sector decision.
If you think about
optimal growth theory,
optimal growth
theory usually says--
let me not do more than
wave my hands at that--
usually says there
are two reasons
you discount the future.
Forget the private
sector for the moment.
If you're doing everything
optimally in the economy,
there are two reasons
you discount the future.
One, there might be a pure rate
of time preference, whatever
that might mean.
And you value benefits in the
future less than benefits today
because people in the
future will be richer.
And, therefore-- being just
a little bit quick with
the hands--
income on the
margin's worth less.
If I were in the future
and I were richer,
then $1 worth of benefit
would be worth less to me
then than it is now.
I'll take that into account.
I'll discount that second
term because people
will be wealthier says,
you make a judgment.
There are formulas.
I won't trouble you.
There are formulas that say,
here's how you deal with that.
And then you say, well,
I have a preference.
We all have preference
for today over tomorrow.
That's a pure rate
of time preference.
The third approach that's
coming into the literature
recently says, why do you have
a pure rate of time preference?
What does that mean?
That discriminates
between generations.
The pure rate of time preference
says, even if my grandchildren
are no richer than
I am, I'm going
to value $1 to them
less than $1 to me.
That doesn't make moral sense.
So I would use a zero rate
of pure time preference
and then make a judgment, if I
want to, about how much richer
they will be and how
much that ought to matter
when I think about benefits.
Now, I present this not--
those are very
different positions.
And they have very
different implications
for how you think
about the future.
And I have to tell
you, depending
on the day of the week and the
weather, I myself vacillate.
But let me just give
you the implications.
Let's take rates to
illustrate these.
7% and 3% are used in federal
government decision making.
The 7%, you might think of as
like a private sector rate.
The 3% gets down to that second
category, the pure rate of time
preference plus an adjustment.
And 1% was used in an
influential report on climate
change that takes the third
position, no pure rate of time
preference, no discrimination
between generations.
So let's apply that to
$1 million in 100 years.
All right, if I use 1%,
that $1 million in 100 years
is worth $368,000.
So I'd spend a fair amount.
I wouldn't spend
$1 million today.
But I'd spend a fair
amount to avoid a 1 million
dollar's worth of damages.
3%, woo.
I wouldn't spend
very much at all
to avoid 1 million
dollar's worth of damages.
And at 7%, we get what a
guy who used to work for me
called the magic ray gun.
You let me discount anything at
7% in the future, it goes away.
It's a disappearing function.
I would spend $9,000 today to
avoid 1 million dollar's worth
of damages in 100 years if
I use that discount rate.
It matters a lot.
And there's no
easy way to decide,
I think, to decide
among these views.
If you scratch most economists,
they come down here at 3%.
But if you ask them,
well, wait a minute.
Aren't you crowding out
private investments?
They say, oh, well, maybe.
Maybe not.
And if you ask them, well,
why are you discriminating
against future generations
with this pure rate of time
preference?
Where does that come from?
Most people go, well,
yeah, that's a point.
So you can make arguments
for all three of these.
And they have very
different implications.
The tsar will have to choose.
See the issue?
I hope.
If you're talking about
five years, 10 years,
it doesn't matter that much.
If you're talking about 100
years, which we are here,
it does, or more.
OK, that's hard.
And it's hard for the tsar.
It's not just hard politically.
So that's one reason
why it's hard.
The tsar is willing to
make sacrifices today
for generations not yet
born or even thought of.
Many other people, who aren't
as farsighted as the tsar,
may have trouble doing
that or voting to do that.
That's a tough trade off, right?
We could reduce
emissions today sharply,
and it wouldn't make
much difference to us,
might not make much
difference to us,
might make some difference
to our children,
might make a lot of
difference to their children.
You can't even imagine having
grandchildren at this point,
right?
All right?
I hope.
But you will.
And so will they.
OK, that's one
reason why it's hard
because it's hard to think
in terms of a century
when you're making
decisions today or more.
A second reason why this
is hard even for the tsar
is uncertainty.
And one of the things Professor
Solomon and I have learned
is you can't say uncertain
in public discourse.
Because uncertain to the
public means, my god,
I don't have a clue.
What uncertain means
in this context is,
I may not know the
probability distribution.
But there is a
It's not oh my.
And it's not
infinitely spread out.
If you think about
elements of uncertainty,
what will the atmosphere
look like in 100 years
if we don't do anything?
Well, you know, that
depends on population.
Does China collapse?
Does China not collapse?
It depends on future
economic growth.
It depends on the
mix of activity.
What happens to manufacturing
versus services?
It depends on new technologies.
Somebody comes up
with cheap storage.
The world moves to solar power.
It's a very different world
than if that doesn't happen.
Those are all big uncertainties.
So we don't really know what
emissions will look like.
There are uncertainties
about the climate system,
serious uncertainties
not that we don't know anything.
But as I mentioned,
there's this issue of,
how fast will the
deep ocean warm?
There are issues of
irreversibility and tipping
points, potentially.
Did you want to talk about
that and say a word about some
of these uncertainties?
Can I provoke you
into a comment?
SUSAN SOLOMON: Possibly.
I guess I'm not quite sure
where you want to go with it.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Oh, I just
want some illustrative detail
or some examples of things
that might be a concern
or that might be
nonlinearities or that might
be like falling off a table.
SUSAN SOLOMON: OK.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You
want to take a second?
Just take a second.
I hate to waste the resource.
SUSAN SOLOMON: I'll do my best.
This issue of tipping
points, in my mind,
is actually a lot more
difficult than the issue
of irreversibility.
The irreversibility problem,
we can talk about a little bit
more clearly.
For example, if it were to
be the case that Arctic sea
ice were to disappear,
you might imagine
that that would be an
irreversible process.
But I think we're
finding, more and more,
that it actually isn't.
Even though we had very
low Arctic sea ice in 2007,
because we have
such cold winters,
we have the ability to reform
the sea ice because it's thin.
Even when you have
multiyear ice,
it's still relatively thin.
It's only a few
years that matters.
But when we, for
example, do something
that causes a big dent in
the Greenland ice sheet,
now that truly is
something that you could
think about as irreversible.
It's going to take a
very, very long time.
So on human timescales, it's
essentially irreversible
if you lose a big piece of
the Greenland ice sheet.
Is there a tipping point
beyond which the Greenland ice
sheet might kind of
suddenly fall apart
is something that's been raised.
Much more of a
controversial issue.
It's conceivable.
But most scientists
who study the ice
would argue that it's more
likely to be a slow process.
But it's possible.
And one of the
things that could be
a tipping point for the
Arctic, that people have also
talked about, of course,
is methane release
from things like undersea
deposits of methane
that are actually tied up in
formations called clathrates
and also in permafrost,
which you're probably
more familiar with.
So there are ways
to trigger things
that, in the tipping point
framework, usually involve ice.
And you can sort of
see why that would be.
It's either ice, or it's not.
There is slow transition
from one to another.
It's a real change of state.
So that's some ideas.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
Thank you.
So that's hard.
The tsar has to think about
those possibilities, which
we know something.
But we don't know.
We can't tell when
that might occur,
if those things might occur.
Even climate models,
complex simulation models
of the climate system--
and there are a number of them--
disagree on what
happens regionally.
Will it be wetter or drier?
Well, that matters a lot.
It matters a lot whether
it'll be wetter or drier
in particular areas.
Well, let me just say that.
Also, we don't have
good predictions
for the impacts on hurricanes,
more, more intense,
none of the above.
More water goes into the
air because it's warmer.
It comes down.
How does it come down?
Where does it come down?
Very uncertain implications
for regional impacts.
Regional impacts will
take us into new ground,
particularly for ecosystems.
We don't quite know how
ecosystems will respond
because we haven't done it.
It's not an easy experiment.
So damages, effects like
rainfall are uncertain.
The implications of those
effects are also uncertain.
And finally, there's
little experience
in sort of, how do human
civilizations react
to large-scale environmental
changes of various kinds?
I've been seeing, on
Google News, reference
to small changes
in rainfall being
the likely culprit in the
downfall of the Mayans,
maybe 20%, 30% reductions,
not huge droughts.
Sensitive enough.
Are poor countries in the
tropics that sensitive?
Probably not.
How sensitive?
All right, finally, the
cost of emissions reductions
are also uncertain.
So the tsar is going to
have to deal with this.
And the tsar is going to
have to deal with the fact
that we will be
learning as we go.
So this is I now go to my
favorite picture from the--
so you can't do cost
benefit analysis because you
don't know the cost.
And you don't know the benefits.
So the tsar can't
just do the arithmetic
because he doesn't know
the cost or the benefits,
even if he could
do the discounting.
A problem like this needs
adaptive or iterative risk
management.
And you can read that in
the report of the Committee
on America's Climate Choices,
on which Professor Solomon and I
both served.
If you think about steering a
ship in iceberg-infested waters
at night before radar,
to avoid the Titanic,
the elements of what a
sensible skipper does
are the elements of
what the tsar would
do to deal with climate.
You slow down.
Good plan.
So you reduce emissions.
You don't quite know
what the consequences
are of having more emissions
or of going faster.
But you know they're
probably not good on balance.
So you slow down.
You prepare for
something to happen.
You prepare to adapt.
You learn.
You station lookouts.
You study the system.
You see what's going on.
You develop options, new
technologies, geoengineering,
which I'll talk about briefly.
And you try to figure
out a system that enables
learning to affect decisions.
So you want to hear the lookouts
when they see something.
So that's the sort
of thing the tsar
is going to have to do because
we don't know probabilities.
We don't know, really,
models and studies
of what's going to happen
to the Greenland ice sheet.
But we don't know for sure.
We don't know for sure.
And we don't know
for sure whether it's
going to get wetter
or drier in Ethiopia.
So just a word about
adaptation, the tsar
will have to have
to do some of this.
But as I said, the small scale--
and we will adapt.
That first line is one
of my favorite statements
about adaptation, which is,
the default mode of adaptation
is suffering.
So we'll adapt.
But the question is, will
we actually do any changes?
Will we do any
proactive adaptation?
As I said, problem one is that
the climate models differ.
And I will give you an example.
A colleague was called in by
the government of Ethiopia
some years ago.
And they said, all
right, we believe there's
going to be climate change.
What do we do?
Half the climate models say
it's going to get drier.
And half the climate models
say it's going to get wetter.
How exactly do we prepare
for this uncertain future?
Their answer was pave the roads.
Because if it's drier,
OK, you have paved roads.
If it's wetter, a problem that
Ethiopia traditionally has
is that unpaved roads wash out
when there's heavy rainfall.
And the whole process of getting
food to market breaks down.
So if it gets wetter, you
will really need paved roads.
And if it doesn't get
wetter, paved roads
are not a bad thing to have.
There are going to
be a lot of decisions
like that, a lot of people
looking for robust policies.
The second problem, of course,
is the tsar can't possibly
make all these decisions.
They're going to be made
at state and local levels.
A number of cities and states
have now, already in the US
and certainly foreign
countries, have now
processes in place to think
about this, to try to think
about things as Ethiopia did.
What can we do that's robust?
If we're going to have sea level
rise, how do we cope with that?
What do we need to
do about hurricanes?
How do we change
various policies?
An awful lot of that is local.
Awful lot of that
has to be local.
An awful lot of that's going
to be in poor countries.
So adaptation will happen.
The tsar will try to do
something about that.
But that, one hopes,
is not enough.
No one doubts that will
be enough to really get us
smoothly.
New technologies,
you guys are going
to develop new technologies.
That's going to be terrific.
What's the tsar going
to do about that?
Well, we'll come back
to some of these issues.
But governments have
a terrible record
of pushing the development
of civilian technologies.
Military technologies,
space technologies,
where cost doesn't matter, fine.
Basic research, fine.
Getting stuff to market at a
reasonable price, bad record.
So you can't adapt.
And you can't solve
it with technology.
You got to reduce emissions.
Why is reducing emissions hard?
Oh, well, let me
first fossil fuels.
Another thing you might
think about doing,
and you've probably read
about, is geoengineering.
The simplest way to think about
that is artificial volcanoes.
You might put sulfate.
When Mount Pinatubo blew
up, as I understand it,
there was a discernible cooling.
Small particles, aerosols in the
stratosphere reflect sunlight.
So why don't we just either burn
more coal or take the 16-inch
guns from battleships that
aren't in use anymore,
turn them up, and fire aerosols
into the stratosphere--
this is a serious proposal--
to reflect sunlight?
Well, you might want to have
that in your back pocket
for emergencies.
But, first of all, if you have
more CO2 in the atmosphere,
the ocean becomes more acidic.
And creatures die.
Doesn't solve that problem.
And second, if you
don't reduce emissions,
you've got to keep doing
more and more of that.
And that does not sound like
a long-term way forward.
So CO2 is where
the policy focus is
because, as we saw from
those earlier graphs,
it's quite important.
It lasts a long time.
We can measure fossil
fuel use pretty easily.
Think about countries
that import all their oil.
You can measure
imports pretty easily
at the ports where they happen.
You may be wrong, plus or
minus inventory accumulation.
But it's not easy
to carry and not
cheap to carry inventories of
crude oil and refined product.
So in terms of internationally
enforceable agreements,
fossil fuel is pretty easy
compared to anything else
you want to think about.
Another reason you focus on it
is we talked about last week.
Not only does it
involve durable assets
that can last a long
time, that are expensive,
and, thus, expensive
to replace early,
but there are all these
other path dependencies
that keep you down a path.
So that if you want to--
so the energy system
is a slow ship to turn.
And if you need to turn
it because its impact last
100 years and if you
can turn it because you
can monitor and enforce, that's
a logical place to focus.
Why is that problem hard?
Why is it hard to
change emissions?
Well, we talked about that.
This is some color-coded,
not very well color-coded
emissions trajectories
on the left matched
with atmospheric CO2
concentrations on the right
and matched down here, except
for the really aggressive
reduction scenario, matched
with temperature increases.
So the world runs on fossil
fuels to a first approximation.
You saw all those
Lawrence Livermore graphs
of sources of energy.
Most of it's fossil.
The world runs on fossil fuels.
Big emission cuts
are needed if you're
going to reduce temperature.
Take the you might think
of the orange kind of as
an estimate of business as usual
maybe, somebody's estimate.
The blue then is a
pretty aggressive cut.
But look what and the blue
relative to the orange,
at the end of the century,
has a pretty big impact
on atmospheric concentrations.
But the temperature
still goes up.
The temperature still
goes up substantially.
That's a two-degree or is
that a three-degree increase
in temperature?
Three degrees Fahrenheit
increase in temperature.
The orange, much bigger.
But that's a big
change, right, if you're
going from here to here?
China's not getting rich
burning coal on the blue path.
We're not increasing our
energy at all probably.
Europe is cutting
back even farther
to get to that blue path.
That's a big deal.
So if it's the
easiest thing to do
and it's an important thing
to do, it's a big deal.
So that's one reason
why it's hard is
we live on fossil fuels.
So if you're going to cut
the use of fossil fuels,
emissions from fossil fuels--
it's emissions
from fossil fuels--
you could do some
fuel switching.
You can do some efficiency.
You can do some this,
that, and the other.
But you will have to do a lot.
New technologies
will be essential.
But they may or may
not appear in time.
OK, so that's a big deal.
So we all go to bicycles.
That's great.
We can do that.
We can emulate the Dutch.
And we can all bicycle to work.
But we're not the problem.
Any projection of the future
says the growth in emissions
will come from countries
that are now poor.
They have been
growing more rapidly
than countries that are
now rich for some time.
And all projections are
they will continue to do so.
So this is from
BP's energy outlook.
If you look up to 2010,
it's 1990 to 2010,
you'll see OECD emissions, rich
country emissions, pretty flat.
I mean, they'd be up a bit but
for the recession but not much.
But dramatic growth in
the less rich countries,
dramatic growth.
Again, for the world as
a whole, energy and CO2
have grown less
rapidly than GDP.
That declining we saw in the
US is a general phenomenon.
But if you try to
control global emissions,
try to reduce global emissions
by reducing OECD emissions,
you see if we go to zero by
2030 and the non-OECD proceeds
on the track, global emissions
will be up, just by eye.
So yeah, Sam?
AUDIENCE: It says that's as soon
as [INAUDIBLE] policy changes.
Any idea what those could be?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
You read the report,
and you say, well,
what are they assuming?
They're assuming tightening
restrictions in Europe.
They're assuming
something in the US.
They're assuming continued
efficiency increases.
They're not assuming the
kind of global agreement
you guys are going to
negotiate Wednesday and Friday.
That's clear.
They're not assuming a
second Kyoto Protocol
ratified by the whole world.
I think, and it's an
interesting assumption
to assume that, absent anything
going on in these countries,
that these countries
will continue.
I mean, here, they're showing a
reduction, a positive reduction
in emissions here
over that period.
So that is-- and there's
growth, not huge growth.
But there's growth.
So they're assuming a
tightening in the OECD,
continued efficiency
increases here.
There's some discussion of
China becoming a bit less carbon
intensive.
But the main policy
action's here.
And they do not assume
a global agreement.
It's a short description.
I invite you to read it.
It's about two pages.
See what you think
they assume, but that's
what I get out of it.
You can see they're continuing
to assume for the world,
as a whole, efficiency
increases, right?
The GDP grows much more
rapidly than energy use.
And they're continuing
to assume for the world,
as a whole, decarbonization,
presumably, presumably
a switch out of coal into
natural gas and renewables.
I'd have to go back
and check, but I think
that's part of the scenario.
Anything else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How big is the impact
on emissions, like methane?
I know that it keeps more heat.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Methane has a--
the reason for not
focusing on methane,
even though it is a more
potent heat-trapping gas,
it doesn't stay in the
atmosphere as long,
A. So it's about 10 year half
life, ballpark, about 10 years.
And, B, it's harder to figure.
It has many sources.
So it's got natural gas leaks.
It's got landfill decomposition.
It's got things rotting.
So it's harder to control.
And in fact, in 20 years,
30 years, less serious.
Yeah?
Please.
SUSAN SOLOMON: I think part
of the confusion on methane
is that, although every
molecule of methane
is more potent than
a molecule of CO2,
there is a lot more
CO2 in the atmosphere.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
SUSAN SOLOMON: So
actually, CO2 is
doing three times
more warming right
now than the total
of all methane
because there's so
much more out there.
Even though heat-trapping
molecules are stronger there.
OK?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Yeah, I didn't do that.
SUSAN SOLOMON: So it's
not the main thing.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Yeah, I didn't do that.
I should have done it.
SUSAN SOLOMON: This
is the main thing.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
I should have done it.
Yeah, if you break down sources
of anthropogenic warming,
CO2 dominates.
SUSAN SOLOMON: When people get
to talking about methane being
an effective greenhouse gas,
it can get very confusing
for people.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So the point is the
graph is built on CO2 emissions
by the OECD countries and
non-OECD countries, right?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yep.
AUDIENCE: But in
general population,
I think the OECD countries--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
We're going to come there.
We're going to break it down.
Yes, you are.
In terms of per capita, the
OECD countries are much higher.
But the only point
to be made here
is, if you want this
top graph to come down,
you're not going
to get it all here.
And you got to do something
up here somehow, somehow.
We will come to questions
of fairness in about a half
a second.
So that's a reason.
You're going to have
to deal with growth.
And the growth is going to come
from countries that are now
poorer than the OECD countries.
The other reason,
let me just briefly
do a little economics
here as opposed
to a little pseudo-science.
Suppose you want to
reduce emissions.
Say you want a total
reduction in emissions
from business as
usual of capital R.
And you want to do it worldwide.
And the cost of getting
reductions in country I
is given by this cost function.
All right, so the tsar
cares about global cost.
So what the tsar is going
to do is reduce emissions.
He's going to minimize
the total cost
subject to this constraint.
And if you recall or
just use your intuition,
you're going to have to have the
marginal cost, the derivative
of this function with
respect to its argument
equal across countries.
If not, I can
rearrange reductions
in a way that will lower costs.
I'll do a little more
where marginal cost is
low and a little less where
marginal cost is high.
Get the same
reductions, lower cost.
That's always true unless
the marginal costs are equal.
Well, if marginal
costs are going
to be equal, then unless it's
really hard to reduce emissions
in poor countries, they
have to play if we're
going to reduce total cost.
It's not a question
of who pays for it.
It's a question of
where it happens, right?
Doesn't say that that Bangladesh
has to pay to reduce emissions
in Bangladesh.
It says that emissions
in Bangladesh
will have to be reduced.
So they're separate questions.
But it says the poor
will need to be involved.
If you recall 1401, if
you have a firm producing
in multiple plants, this is
exactly the same principle.
You want to equalize
on the margin.
Normally, it means
everybody has to play.
There are two
approaches that have
been put on the table for this.
And we'll come back
to both of them.
The Parsons, et al,
piece on the reading
list, which is optional,
talks about one of them.
You could say, all right,
how about the tsar says
there's a price of
$20 a ton for carbon
emissions from fossil fuels?
The tsar doesn't like
to do central planning.
He's learned that lesson.
But the tsar can
tinker with prices.
So he'll put a price of
$20 a ton for emissions.
Well, that means everybody
who's contemplating emissions
is going to cut back until
the cost of cutting back rises
to $20.
And I'll get this marginal
cost of quality that way.
All right, so I'll
just price the thing.
We talked about this earlier.
This is pricing the harm.
So I priced the harm.
People cut back on the harm.
It's a tax.
It'll show up as a tax, probably
show up as a tax on fuel.
Tax much higher on coal
than on natural gas.
But that's one way to do it.
And the tsar can do that.
The other way to do it--
that makes sense, right?
That's easy?
We just price the thing.
The other way to do it is a
little more convoluted but only
a little more.
And we'll return
to the equivalence
later on is the tsar prints
up certificates, drops
from helicopters, and
says, to emit a ton of CO2,
you have to give
me a certificate.
Limited number of certificates
equal to the total amount
of CO2 the tsar wants to
permit, you get a market, right?
I go around looking
for certificates.
I'm willing to pay
20 bucks for it.
I'm willing to pay some price.
The market will
determine what price.
In this case, if I fix
a price, the market
will determine the quantity.
If I fix a quantity, the market
will determine the price.
But I can go either way.
And if the tsar
knows all, it doesn't
matter which way he goes.
We'll talk a little
later, I think,
about when and where
and how it might matter.
But that's what the
tsar might want to do.
But do those make sort
of top of the head sense
as a way to do it without having
to do central planning for all
the nations of the world?
But if you say it's
$30 a ton or $40 a ton
for everybody and poor
countries have to pay it,
how do they do that?
How do they do that?
So you know that they're going
to have to do some reduction.
Because if you think
about it, they're
building buildings,
facilities, et cetera.
It's a lot cheaper to
insulate a new house
when it's being built than to go
back and retrofit an old house.
It's a lot cheaper to make
a new power plant efficient
than to repower an
old power plant.
So if the poorer
countries of the world
are growing more
rapidly, they have
a lot more relatively
inexpensive investment
opportunities.
They also may not have
built Los Angeles yet.
So they're in a position
to decide more easily
on a different urban
structure, less spread out,
less reliant on cars.
So there are a set of
choices that are being made.
There are also, if you
look at retrofit options,
there's a lot of energy use
now that is polluting as well
as inefficient.
So modernizing some
of the plants now
will create a double benefit.
If you can do something besides
little kerosene generators,
for instance, for electricity
in a lot of places,
you will not only save
energy, but you clean the air.
So there's a benefit
to be had in bringing
these countries closer to the
frontier with what they already
have.
OK.
So this is a hard
problem for the tsar.
The tsar has to figure
out how she's going to--
or the tsarina, how
she's going to deal
with the distant future and
great-great-grandchildren,
how to deal with
uncertainty today
and to learn to deal with a
tomorrow as learning happens.
The tsar is going to have to
figure out what, if anything,
could be done about
technologies, how to get people
and able to adapt.
If the tsar focuses
on fossil fuel,
the tsar has to
make big changes.
And the tsar has to
involve the poor.
The tsar has to
It can't be done
by rich countries.
If rich countries
alone try to do it,
if you go back to something like
this, you want to slow growth.
You want to eliminate
growth in emissions
by only the rich
countries, they'd
have to go to zero
to have a big impact.
It isn't going to happen.
So the pole need to be involved.
And the first question that
comes up, already came up,
is that fair?
This is emissions per capita.
This is Annex II North
America is US and Canada.
This is Australia,
New Zealand, Japan.
EIT, or Economies In
Transition, that's
Russia and Eastern Europe.
There's the Middle East.
Annex II Europe or rich
European countries,
China, other countries, Latin
America, the rest of Asia,
Africa.
Is it fair to involve them?
My golly.
You're going to go to Cambodia.
You remember I put up the
Cambodia energy diagram
some while ago.
Cambodia imports some oil
and burns a lot of wood.
That's the energy system.
And they mostly ride motorbikes.
And you can't get them
much smaller than the ones
they have.
So this is an enormous
disparity, right?
North America is running--
I don't know--
16 metric tons per capita.
Africa is running less than one.
Big disparity.
Huge disparity.
Very different.
Very different systems.
So if you're going
to change, you're
going to look
people in the face.
And those of you who want
to be developing countries
or developed countries
on Wednesday and Friday
are going to look your poor
brethren in the face and say,
you, Latin America,
rest of Asia, Africa,
boy, you've got to take steps.
We'll do what we can.
But you've got to take steps.
Say, we have path
dependence up here.
We're kind of stuck on a path.
And you know, what
are you going to do?
So fairness is also in one
response might be, yeah, well,
let's look not per capita.
But you're low because
you're really, really poor.
And we're really,
really sad about it.
But per dollar of GDP, the
differences are less stark.
The winners now are the
Middle East, Soviet Union,
and Eastern Europe
because those were really
manufacturing-intensive
technologies.
They ran on cheap
Russian oil, which
was made available at low
cost, and Russian natural gas.
They still have an anomalous
amount of inefficient capital
stock running.
And China, which has a
manufacturing-intensive economy
and uses a lot of coal.
So per unit of GDP, Africa is
right in there with everybody
else.
They just happen to have
not much GDP per capita.
So you say, well, per dollar
of GDP, we can make cuts.
You can make cuts.
And one response might be, yeah,
but we'd like our GDP to grow.
Thank you very much.
So this is another nice example.
This is if you do
the cumulative,
you do what's in the air,
which was the point Professor
Solomon was making, if
you do what's in the air,
this is just CO2.
But it shows,
cumulatively, what's
in the air now based on a model
of the carbon cycle, what's
in the air now and
where it came from.
Blue is the rich countries.
This is kind of middle
income developing countries.
And that's the very poor.
So in terms of who
caused the problem, who
put the stuff in the
air, it's not China.
Who's putting it in the
air and who's growing?
Yeah.
But who put it there?
It's us.
OK.
A little bit of sort of how
the international conversation
on all of this has gone,
just by way of background,
and then we'll see
what questions you have
because I've gone through
this much too rapidly.
As I mentioned, the Framework
Convention on Climate Change
was drafted in 1992,
ratified by everybody.
There have been 17 conferences
of the parties referred
to as COPs, large
gatherings of diplomats,
nongovernmental organizations,
demonstrators, hangers on,
cocktail parties, receptions.
There have been 17 of them.
You will be the 18th.
The third produced
the Kyoto Protocol.
The Framework Convention
divided the world
into Annex I countries
and everybody else.
Annex II, which was on some
of those earlier graphs,
is a subset of Annex I. It's
the richer Annex I countries.
The Kyoto Protocol called
for Annex I countries only.
And by the way, it's
not all rich countries.
South Korea is not
Annex I. Singapore
is not Annex I. Saudi Arabia
is not Annex I and so forth.
So it's industrialized
countries.
OECD, roughly, OECD.
Annex I countries were
to make reductions that
were negotiated reductions.
The rest of the
world, which I just
said has to participate if
something's going to happen,
refused to even promise
making promises in the future.
So there wasn't
even a commitment
to make a commitment.
They would not commit to commit.
And if you think about that,
that's really resisting.
We'll be happy to come
to these meetings.
But we do not now promise
ever to commit to do anything,
unless, of course,
it's paid for.
So the Kyoto Protocol
called for Annex I countries
to make reductions.
It was ratified by the members
of the European Union, Japan,
Australia, Canada,
lots of other folks.
We did not.
The history of that is roughly
that President Clinton,
in the run up to
those negotiations,
there was a lot of noise
in the air about how
this will be free.
It'll be a great benefit
to the US economy.
This will be fabulous.
We can reduce emissions.
It'll be no cost.
Every economist not working
for the administration stood up
and said, well, it's not
going to cost that much money,
but it will cost.
Congress passed a resolution
95 to nothing saying,
we won't ratify anything that--
basically, slightly
different language--
that doesn't require the
Chinese to do something now.
95 to nothing.
So Al Gore went to Kyoto.
The US said, this is fabulous.
We made an agreement.
The treaty was not sent to
the Senate for ratification.
And President George
W. Bush formally
declared the horse dead
in 2001 when he said,
we're not going to play.
So the EU has
established-- and again,
you can read the Parsons, et
al, article if you're interested
in it--
established an emissions
trading scheme.
They did the certificates
dropped from the air that
lets you emit carbon dioxide.
I mean, it's not
a perfect system.
You'll see some glitches.
But it may work.
And they may actually
meet their commitments.
It doesn't appear
anybody else will,
even those that
ratified the treaty.
Australia's walking away.
I think Canada has walked away.
Japan may because of
the incredible disaster
they've gone through but
would not have absent it
and may not since they now
say that they will replace
the nuclear plants with coal.
So we'll see.
But at any rate,
nothing will happen.
The subsequent
agreements, there was
Copenhagen. There was a lot of
fuss around Copenhagen. You'll
see the run up discussed
in The Economist reading.
You will see the most
recent Doha discussed
in the second very
short Economist
reading, happened in December.
There's no global
agreement in place.
What happened in Doha, and it's
on my slides for Wednesday,
but I'll tell you now.
What happened in
Doha was basically
the Europeans
agreed to continue.
There was a promise of money
to go from the rich countries
to the poor countries,
a much smaller promise
than you will consider
Wednesday and Friday.
But there was a promise.
We'll see if it's kept.
And the developing
world promised
to consider making promises.
That is to say the
refusal to commit ever
to commit is off the table.
They now say they will consider,
in subsequent negotiations
beginning in 2015,
participating in a global regime
of some sort, not
fully spelled out.
So the poor countries,
as I say, need
to participate, have managed
to be excluded so far.
The task you will face on
Wednesday and Friday is to,
and I hope do it
with a straight face,
is to make proposals that have
some hope of being accepted
when you go back to your
capitals of emissions
reductions that will get
the job done globally.
OK, I've covered a lot.
And I'm going to pause here.
I hate to quit this early.
But let me see if you have
questions or comments.
How do we do this?
Have you all read the
briefing materials?
No?
They're up for
Wednesday, I guess.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
$1 billion per year
to stay within that 2
degrees Celsius rise?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
2 degrees Celsius,
which is what we're
working with because that's
how the exercise was set, is
really ambitious at this stage.
I mean, it is the
goal that was adopted
in Copenhagen. It's a very
ambitious goal at this stage.
It might not have been so
ambitious 20 years ago.
But now more stuff in the air.
Stuff going to stay a long time.
Steeper reduction is called for.
Yeah, I mean, who knows
what it's going to take?
But it's not going to
be a walk in the part.
It's going to be serious money.
AUDIENCE: I thought that was
interesting because $1 trillion
is less than a percent of
the entire world's GDP.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It is.
It is.
But as they say in Washington,
you've got only 100
of those percents to play with.
And so less than 1% sounds
small until you start saying,
what does that mean we don't do?
1% of the household
budget, easy.
But 1% of-- moving 1% of world
GDP from purpose A to purpose B
requires governments
to do serious things.
Deciding to cut
back 1% yourself,
yeah, you can do that.
It's nothing.
But deciding that US is going to
increase spending on something
by 1%, A, that's a
bigger percentage
of government activity.
And, B, you're going to
have to tax, spend, torque,
regulate, do significant things.
So yeah, it's only 1% of GDP.
And all the models
say that's sort
of the right order of magnitude
for the kinds of things you'll
need to do, 1%, maybe 2%.
But that sounds
easier than it is.
Let me just say that.
Yeah, David?
AUDIENCE: You're talking
about the Kyoto Protocol
and how basically the
EU is the only one
who even had a chance of
meeting what they promised.
What's been proposed to kind
make sure that people actually
meet what they said?
So say, I'm the EU and I
spent all this money trying
to control our CO2 emissions.
We did our part.
And no one else did.
And it's really not going
to make a difference.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, there's
no enforcement mechanism
in the protocol.
I don't know that the
Framework Convention even
allows for the possibility
of an enforcement mechanism.
I'd have to go back and look.
For simple international
agreements ,
it hasn't mattered much.
The Montreal Protocol to phase
out ozone-depleting substances,
widely ratified not perfect.
There are some illegal
manufacturing here and there.
But basically, it's tiny.
So most governments can
afford to just do it.
Most countries can
afford to do it.
It's a rich countries
use those chemicals more
than poor countries.
Rich countries can
afford substitutes,
not perfect, but cheap.
This, not so cheap.
And so no enforcement mechanism
there either, as far as I know.
I don't think there was.
In any case, it was
never seriously deployed.
Here, what would you do?
I mean, the Europeans
are ready to go.
Everybody was very excited.
Al Gore flew to Kyoto.
It was high times.
And to say the US has always
talked about monitoring.
No matter who the
president's been,
we always talk about monitoring
in these kinds of discussions.
Nobody listens to us much now.
But we always say,
gee, you ought
to actually know if somebody
is obeying the agreement.
That's resisted by
a lot of countries.
So no.
And you can now
imagine the beginnings
of a European reaction.
Wait a minute.
We're doing all this?
And what are all these
other people doing?
They're smiling at us.
It raises the cost of
our heavy industry,
our energy-intensive industry.
And wait a minute.
Why are we doing this again?
Because it's not going to
have any effect, right?
I mean, Europe is a relatively--
relative to those
big charts, the kind
of reductions that
Europe's making
are hard to see
on the aggregate.
If I go back to--
that's the one.
If I go back to this one,
Europe might be the width
of this down at some cost.
So you can imagine
the European public
being less and less excited just
as they've begun to phase down
subsidies for renewable energy.
So yeah, that's
part of the problem.
The tsar can enforce.
We do not have a tsar.
AUDIENCE: So the Senate
passed a resolution
saying they won't
approve anything
that doesn't force China to
also have emissions reductions?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Didn't say force.
You can't use force because
none of these agreements--
unless it requires,
which is to say
that China signs on to something
that says it will do x.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But it doesn't
specify that they
have to actually be monitored?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Oh, I can't imagine.
I This country's
got a long history
of strategic arms reduction.
Do you remember-- well,
you wouldn't remember.
But you may have heard
people say trust but verify.
We've always had that
view internationally.
We want to make sure
if we're going to obey,
we're going to make sure
other people do too,
at least monitor.
You may not be able to enforce.
So I can't see us signing
something, ratifying
something that doesn't have at
least monitoring provisions.
Enforcement, look at attempts
to take action against Syria.
The world community doesn't
lightly enforce stuff.
But every so often, Syria,
Iran, something gets done.
But doesn't get done easily.
Doesn't get done automatically.
It's a big political deal.
David?
AUDIENCE: How is this not led
to a stronger partnership laws?
In that, I see it as a place
where a more developed nation
that has high technology
institutions like MIT
could come in and talk
to a place like that.
There's already a fair amount
of infrastructure investment
that's made.
And a lot of it can be in the
terms of low-interest loans
or provide experts to help
build up the infrastructure
because your cost is lower.
And you're developing
something new.
And you're fostering global
investment here in the States
by making that part of your--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Available.
AUDIENCE: --value add.
You're also helping
internationally.
How is that not happening?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
it happens to some extent.
There's a problem of
measurement, right?
The European system--
the Kyoto Protocol
provides for joint
implementation.
Well, I forget the
exact language.
Hmm?
The Clean Development
Mechanism, CDM.
If you're a European
company, you
can meet some of
your obligations
by reducing emissions
in a poor country.
So you can go to China and do a
deal, bring in new technology,
do something that
will reduce emissions.
And that will give you credit.
And that's exactly
that kind of thinking.
Even though China
isn't participating,
it's still cheaper to
do reductions there.
So let's find a way to give
countries in Europe credit
for reductions in China.
There are a couple of problems.
Well, it all boils
down to one problem
really, which is, how
do you measure it?
Because you're reducing
over what would have been.
So you modernize a factory.
So would that factory
have been running forever
with old technology?
Or would it have been torn down?
Or would it have been
modernized anyway?
So either you're real
light on how you do this,
and you don't impose
real tough restrictions
and then you're not
getting real reductions.
Or you make it really
hard to document.
In which case, you
kill the market.
So it happens.
And it happens to some extent.
The Europeans have gotten
a little tired of it,
as I recall, thinking that
it's been a little too easy.
But one of the features of the
Waxman-Markey bill in the US,
which was the cap and trade
bill-- it was killed--
it allowed for that.
It covered only fossil fuels.
But it allowed
companies to get credit
for things done in agriculture.
So you could change land use.
And it was a giveaway
to agriculture
basically because the standards
were going to be pretty easy.
But it was that
same notion that I
want to reach out beyond
places that I can price
to give people incentives.
But it's really hard because
you can measure what is emitted.
You can never measure
what would have been.
You could see the same
problem with forests
if you think for just a minute.
If I pay you not to
cut down a forest,
does that mean the
guy across the street
cuts his down to provide
the timber or what?
And you would never have cut
it down or you would have?
So it's a natural model.
If there were a common regime,
a cap and trade or a tax regime,
that would happen
automatically, easily.
And you wouldn't have
a measurement problem.
It's just hard to do it
without such a thing.
US companies, there's some
sort of informal trading
in carbon credits in the.
US and companies will
do stuff like this
and take credit for it.
Perfectly fine activities.
It's socially
responsible and all that.
But it's just hard to assess.
AUDIENCE: Where's the
developing nation resistance?
They're getting investment,
why would they not want to?
Besides the
measurement problem, I
would see it as someone
who's trying to get
foreign investment anyway.
And you take out full-page
ads in [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, what they're
worried about is
you guys got rich.
We want to get rich.
You guys got rich
burning fossil fuel.
And you're telling us--
I assume I'm going to
hear a bunch of this
on Wednesday and Friday
from the developing world.
You're telling us that
you got to do that.
And you're now leaning on us.
The fear isn't that
boatloads of investment
will come in and
modernize their factory.
The fear is that you're going
to raise the price of fuel
to my poor people.
A lot of these countries
subsidize fuel.
And I don't want to
take the political heat
from something that
restricts my ability to grow.
If you're telling me
that the Europeans are
going to come in and modernize
my factories, that's swell.
I love it.
If you're telling me
that I have to change
my policies in a way that
might slow growth and keep
my people poor, I'm
not real excited.
And you can say
I've been talking
about your grandchildren
and great-grandchildren.
Well, I mean, if your
kids are starving today,
that's a pretty
abstract argument.
That's real abstract.
So other comments, reactions,
questions, thoughts?
Oh, yeah?
AUDIENCE: So mostly we've been
talking about greenhouse gases.
Is there any
international discussion
about other like
climate-changing courses,
like the black carbon or other
like aerosols, or is that not?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Not that I'm aware of.
Is there some?
SUSAN SOLOMON: Yes.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
Say.
SUSAN SOLOMON: Well,
I mean, the State
Department, just a few weeks
ago, announced that we would--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So
they will capture you on--
you didn't sign a release
form, but never mind.
SUSAN SOLOMON: I release you.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: And
everyone is released out there
in television land.
OK.
SUSAN SOLOMON: Just
a few weeks ago,
the State Department announced
that we would be part of,
and I guess the
leader of, an effort
to try to reduce
emissions of soot
and other short-lived
gases, stuff
like methane and
tropospheric ozones as well.
So that's a voluntary program.
But there are movements
in that direction.
And there is
actually quite a bit
of investment in providing
very much more efficient stoves
to people in very
poor countries,
so that they can avoid using
things like dung and coal
and stuff like that, which
generates an enormous amount
of pollution.
So it has both a health benefit
and an efficiency benefit.
And it also cuts
carbon a little but.
But realistically,
the main motivation
is much more grounded in soot.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I mean,
one reason, not the main reason
necessarily, to be concerned
with black carbon emissions is
the effect on the reflectivity.
If you have a lot of sea
ice, ice tends to reflect.
Black carbon tends to absorb.
So it does matter for
climate, but it also
matters when you breathe.
There are lots of international
environmental treaties.
Most don't have anything
to do with climate.